in Iran this morning the death toll is
rising from a fire at a prison that
holds political prisoners and at least
two Americans eight people are now
confirmed dead from the fire that
started on Saturday it is now out Iran's
government said that it started during a
fight among inmates but critics dispute
that claim they suspect it's tied to
anti-government protests that have gone
on for nearly a month Remy and incensio
has more
smoke billowed over Iran's Infamous Evan
Prison from a massive fire that ripped
through the facility holding political
prisoners and dual Nationals including
Americans
gunshots echoed projectiles were
launched into the air
just outside anti-government protesters
called for the death of Iran's supreme
leader
there are conflicting narratives about
how this fire started State media
claiming prisoners in this sewing
Workshop started to fight and a fire
broke out spreading towards holding
women and political prisoners when you
hear about Evan you think about torture
Force confession and political
dissidents Mahmoud amri mogadam is a
human rights Observer he says officials
could have instigated the violence what
we have heard more from the prisoners
and their families is that they have
attacked one of the wards and they have
thrown a tear gas inside that has been
shooting inside the prison beating
[Applause]
demonstrations have now been reported in
more than 100 cities and towns sparked
by the death of a 22 year old who died
while in custody of Iran's morality
police allegedly for wearing an improper
head covering but toppling the regime is
now the goal and this time it's
different people have lost their fear
and it's a very bad news for the Iranian
regime the regime has survived more than
four decades and if the clerics were to
be toppled I would say the countdown of
the Islamic Republic has started
and CBS News has now learned that one
iranian-american citizen inside Evan
prison is safe but he has been moved to
solitary confinement his name is Edward
shargi he is there for serving um
Espionage charges but his family says
that he is a political Pawn he's a
political hostage and they're calling on
President Biden to get him out ASAP but
case in point this violence these fires
more urgency letting more urgency to
getting him out as soon as possible Tony
possibly world changing events there in
Iran Remy thank you very much